ABE HASKINS: Can everyone
hear me all right?
Hear me all right?
All right, cool.
So my name is Abe
Haskins, for those of you
who didn't see my session
about 50 minutes ago.
I am a developer programs
engineer on the Firebase team.
Which pretty much
means that my goal
is to help you be successful
with Firebase by talking
to you about the technical
[INAUDIBLE] devices.
Today we're going
to talk specifically
about Firebase Analytics.
So we look at this big
circular world of Firebase,
we start to see an
obvious thing which
is that Firebase
Analytics is the core.
[INAUDIBLE] hidden session
about Firebase Analytics.
That's because Firebase
Analytics is super important.
All of these services tie
into Firebase Analytics
At Firebase we talked about all
the time about building things
that make the lives of
our users users easier.
That means that if you're our
user, your a developer using
Firebase, we want to make
life easier for the people who
are using your products.
And we do this by knowing
them, by understanding them,
and having you
play really compete
idea about who are users are.
But it's not just about
knowing who they are.
It's about having insight, and
making that insight actionable.
So that instead of just saying
I have users, you can say
I have users in
India, who are 18
to 24-years old, who love buying
packs of stickers in my app.
Or I have users
in the Netherlands
who always search for bread.
I don't know why, but they
always search for bread.
This is the type of
insight we want to have,
and then you want to
be able to say, OK
how can we make our
applications experience more
customized, and more natural
for these users, based
on this data.
And so Firebase Analytics
alone is super interesting.
It's a great tool for capturing
data about your users,
about understanding them.
But then, when we
mix it in with all
these other Firebase services
we get a much more complete
picture.
And one of these services
well talk specifically
about today is Remote Config.
We're changing things in your
app based on who your user is.
But all of these
services work really,
really well with
Firebase Analytics,
which is why it's
the core of Firebase.
So here's what we uncover today.
And these slides
are not in English,
so I'm going to try and
remember what they say.
And I believe what
they say is first we're
going to look at the
built in-- nope, getting
started, that's the first one.
Then we'll look at the
built in reporting.
What we did for free, just
by including the Firebase
Analytics SDK.
Then we'll look at how to do
some more advanced reporting.
Reporting custom events.
How that works inside Firebase.
Then we'll look at--
let me think about this.
I know the answer, we're doing
advanced reporting, and then
Google Analytics versus
Firebase Analytics.
Of course, I forget the one
that's written in English.
So we'll look at comparing
Firebase Analytics to Google
Analytics, so we know when to
use what, and how they connect,
and what that whole story is.
And then we'll wrap things up.
So first, if you want to
get started with Firebase
Analytics, if you want to
walk out of here today and get
Firebase Analytics inside
of your mobile app,
you go to firebase.google.com,
or the Chinese localized
equivalent, and create
a new Firebase project.
It takes like two seconds.
If you have an existing
Google project,
maybe you have Google
Sign In, or something
like that enabled
on another project,
you can hit this handy
import Google project button,
and that will bring
it in and turn that
into a Firebase project.
Once we have that we can
go and we can actually
enable Analytics.
And in this picture we see
Firebase Analytics as the core.
And every part of this
feature is broken up
into it's own
library, it's own SDK,
kind of, that we
can pick and choose.
So when I want just
Firebase Analytics,
I ask for the Firebase Core.
And if I want Firebase Remote
Config, or Firebase Dynamic
Links, I can ask
for those two later,
and import those
libraries separately.
But since Analytics is the
core, that's the module
we're going to look at.
So in iOS that's saying,
all right [INAUDIBLE]
is Firebase Core we're
going to include.
And then app delegate,
we [INAUDIBLE].
Now, in Android
it's very similar.
We include com.google.firebase,
Firebase Core, and then
include the Google Services
[INAUDIBLE] plugin.
And this does the equivalent of
correct configure in Android.
It's a little bit
different, but it does
essentially the same thing.
Now with this, once we have
this set up, Analytics is done.
Or it can be if you just
want the basic reporting.
Because right now
Firebase Analytics
is enabled in your app, and
if you ship this out to users
it's going to start
reporting a bunch of data.
And because Firebase
Analytics has
been built by a company who
builds really great mobile apps
and really
understands our users,
we know what is
immediately useful.
The things that are shared
between every single mobile
app that every mobile app
developer wants to know.
And we can start reporting
those to you immediately.
So what is that?
It's all of this data.
So we get, Immediately,
things like
how often things are happening.
We get location
information about where
things are happening.
We get information
about the demographic.
What gender using or app?
How old are they?
All of this
information, including
things like how long
have they been in my app?
How often do they use it?
Have they made any
in-app purchases?
All of this data is collected
by Firebase Analytics
for free, right out of the
gate, with no lines of code.
Or one, if you're in iOS.
So to give some idea what
these automatic events that we
include are, here's a list.
We have the first time
somebody opens an app.
We want to know how many
people are actually opening
our app after they install it.
They will want to know did
they make an in app purchase?
Did they update our app?
Did the OS update?
Did they open a
notification from us?
Did they open a dynamic link?
All these things,
you can see, they
connect out to the
extended Firebase world.
They're related to
other Firebase services,
like opening a dynamic link.
And some of these are just data
we want to know about the user.
Because we want to see if we
get way more crashes in our app
today then we did yesterday,
and we didn't change anything,
why could that be?
Well we could see that
a ton of our users
had an operating system update.
A ton of people just upgraded
to that new version of Android,
and that's causing
some issues for us.
And this is the type of
insight we can get for free
through Firebase Analytics.
So like I said, we
get a bunch of stuff
just immediately for free.
We get all those events
that got triggered
that are just built in.
That are just known as things
that we need from mobile.
And we get utility to just,
for free, discover things.
And this is something I really
love about Firebase Analytics.
It costs basically nothing.
And by basically nothing,
I mean actually nothing.
[INAUDIBLE] into your app.
Firebase Analytics
is completely free,
it's completely unlimited.
So you can go, you
can drop this in,
and then you can go
look at these reports
and say am I actually
understanding
my users like I think I am?
Are they doing what I expect?
Are they using the
devices that I expect.
All of this just by including
those couple lines of code.
To give you some idea
of, specifically,
what we can get out of
it, we can get information
about our users.
So monthly active users.
This is an easy, common
metric for measuring
the value of an app.
How many people use
your app in a month?
And of course we can
see trends over time.
How many people are
engaging in our app?
Did that news article
really make a difference?
Thinks like that.
We can see the ARPU, the
average revenue per user,
and other insight like
that because it is
tied into the rest of Google.
It's tied into your
in-app purchases.
So we immediately get
that type of information.
And you're interested
in receipt validation,
and other parts of the
more complex average value,
average revenue
per user aspects,
we've thought of a
ton of those issues
and already tackled them.
Because we know that's
an issue for our top acts
who want to use an
analytics tool like this.
We also get something
called a retention cohort.
It's my personal
favorite, mostly because I
like the way it looks.
But this is a chart
that will show you
are people staying in your app?
So imagine you had an app.
You have a game, and this
game was really popular
for the first two weeks.
And so in that first
week we'd have 100%,
because if somebody installed
the app they're obviously
going to use it the
first day they use it.
So that first week
will always be 100%.
The second week we have
19% who are still there,
and they're still doing OK.
And in this case we have 12,
so this is a more average drop
off.
But imagine in that third
week it just dropped to zero.
Dropped to like 1% of users
who are still in our app.
This is a situation
where you might
want to reevaluate your app.
And this might not be something
you think to look for.
You might not think to
instrument your app so that you
can see retention cards.
But once this is
here, and you're
looking around and fiddling
with your Firebase Analytics,
you'll probably see that.
And you'll be like,
why the heck are
my [INAUDIBLE] users dropping
off in that third week.
And this is what I mean
by discoverability.
We want you to be able to find
things in Firebase Analytics
that you're not
really looking for.
Because we know the
important things
that app developers need.
And if we know those we can put
them front and center for you,
so you don't have to
spend a lot of time
digging in and doing all
sorts of slicing and dicing
of your data to hopefully
get some [INAUDIBLE].
You can do that, if you want.
If you want to export to
some gigantic database
and analyze every analytics
event ever triggered
for your million users
everywhere in the world,
you can do that with
Firebase Analytics.
But on the surface,
to get started,
we just wanted to be simple
Another chart on the topic
of user engagement and user
retention is the user
engagement section.
We have daily
engagements, or how long
has someone been in your
app on an average day?
How long do they spend?
How many times do
they open the app?
How long do they
spend per session?
All of this core
information just
helps you learn more
about your users.
And we can also correlate this
to in-app purchasing data.
Because this is, again,
related to user engagement.
And one of the ways you could,
if you were interested in it,
measure engagement is
through in-app purchases.
And just generally, the
success of the monetization
of your app.
So if we can easily see
that 96 of our users
are purchasing
something in our app,
we can immediately
get some insight.
And since that purchase
is just a built in event,
it's just an event that
get's added automatically
whenever somebody
purchases something,
we can dig into that.
Now I don't have a
slide to show it here,
but we could easily click on
the users chunk right there
and we could see exactly the
demographic of the people who
have made in-app purchases.
And we can see if they're
parts of other audiences
we've created too.
But we'll dig more
into that in a minute.
Something I love
Firebase Analytics
versus other analytics
tools-- so if you've ever
used Google Analytics,
you probably
know Google Analytics
tries, in general,
to guess what device you're on.
And this is a core split between
Firebase Analytics and Google
Analytics.
Firebase Analytics knows for
sure what device you're on.
Google Analytics
can try and guess.
Can try and look at a user
agent and a web browser and say,
well, we think you're
running Windows XP.
We think you're running
this version of Firefox.
But user agents can lie,
and they can just generally
be very hard to detect.
But with Firebase
Analytics, because it's
built for mobile first, and
because we know mobile devices,
we can build it and we
can make sure we know
exactly what users are doing.
So we can get really
detailed information.
Like the Android operating
system version, or the iOS
operating system version.
And so we see not only who
is using our app today,
but how have they changed.
And we break this down.
So if I have 100
million users in India,
and 50 million users in the US,
and I know that 5% of my users
are running an ancient
version of Android.
Just something abysmally
old, and I'm thinking
of not supporting them anymore.
That's a blind decision to make.
I don't know how many of
my users in each country
are going to be impacted
I could just wildly guess
that 5% in the US and 5%
in India will be affected.
But with this, with
this information,
we can dive into that.
And we can say,
all right, show me
the users who are running
the old Android version.
Show me what country they're in.
And then, based on
that information,
it's really easy to make that
decision in an informed way.
So now we can say yes, this user
is indeed on an old version.
And Interestingly enough, all of
his friends are on old versions
too.
In fact some huge
percentage of India
is on an old version of Android.
So if I make this decision to
stop supporting this version,
it's going to hurt
me in India, but not
really impact my US market.
And these are the important
types of business decisions
we can make with a really
good analytics tool
like Firebase Analytics.
Beyond that, beyond
the data that you get.
Like, we get data
from you, right?
You get data about
your users, report it
to Firebase Analytics, and
you can-- that's great.
But there is
something about Google
which is that it's
kind of magical.
Google is an amazing company
that knows a lot about people.
That's how we build
great products is
by understanding the people
who use our products.
And we have a lot of
information about those people,
because we really
care about them
and want to make sure that what
we're doing fits their needs.
And we want to
share that with you.
So part of Firebase Analytics
is insight about your users
that they did not necessarily
provide through your app.
So for example, if I go in
and I sign up for your app
and I'm just me, you might
get an email address from me,
and you might be able to guess,
oh this is his Twitter profile,
or whatever.
But you won't know who I am,
you won't know how old I am,
you won't know what
my interests are.
But because we can enrich
the data we get from your app
with Google data, you can
get all sorts of information.
So we know where that
person's located,
we can know what their
interests are, how old they are,
what there gender is, because
Google has the ability
to enrich your data.
So you get that extra
sprinkle of Google magic
on top of an already great
Firebase Analytics tool.
And this mixing is
really what we're
trying to do with
Firebase Analytics,
is provide something
that's kind of magical.
You don't have to say
what are your interests?
I'm curious if your
interests are aligned
with what I think they are.
But we have that data
coming in, because Google
can share that with you.
So what happens if we go beyond?
Because this is
the simple usage.
[INAUDIBLE] One to zero lines
of code to get all that benefit.
What is the next step for us?
Well it's logging custom events.
Now a custom event
can be anything.
In this case, choosing
an ice cream flavor.
Why?
Because I love ice cream.
But in reality it
could be anything.
It could be just a
[INAUDIBLE] that says hey,
I joined a newsletter.
Or it could be
something very specific,
like I selected my favorite
flavor of ice cream.
In this case it's
vanilla in a cone.
And that's actually true.
That's delicious.
If we look at this,
once we log that event
it shows up in the
Firebase dashboard.
We can go in and see how
many times these events are
occurring, how [INAUDIBLE]
to how many events
were occurring yesterday.
All sorts of
insights [INAUDIBLE].
We also have the
ability over here
to mark it as a
conversion event.
And once we mark an event
as a conversion event,
that means it's out end goal.
So in this case we have a
bunch of different events,
like the achievements page,
viewed by the app install,
the app updated,
things like that.
We might send out a push
notification, for example.
And the goal of that
push notification
might be to get you
to try a new feature.
So we might mark that tried new
feature event as a conversion
event.
And once we do that
we can go and get
a whole bunch of insight
about that conversion event,
because we've marked
it as an event
that we really care about.
That is our goal.
So we can create funnels and
other complicated analytical
things based off of that
to track if we're actually
getting to our goal once we've
decided what that goal is.
So you click on one
of these events.
One of these custom
events we're logging.
We get a bunch of
interesting information.
We get how often does it happen
over time, how many users
are doing it, how many times
per user is it happening?
And then we have this
interesting thing over here
called value, which is just
zero and a straight line.
I'll talk about in a minute.
But for a simple event
you'll get all of is.
And also, of course, you get
that enriched data from Google.
So it's not just users
triggered this event.
It's all of your female users
in Brazil triggered this event.
And that's so much
more interesting.
That's so much more
compelling if you
know who these people are.
Because now it's
not just like, oh,
a lot more people are
trying this feature.
But we know for some
reason it's connecting
with a certain group.
So if you're interested
in retargeting that group,
making sure they come
back to your app,
you know have the
insight to do that.
And here's us filtering that
same event of the [INAUDIBLE]
page views based on gender.
And this is what I'm
talking about when
I say we can slice
and dice the data,
and look at it in a
bunch of cool ways.
So we see now we're just
seeing the subset of users
who are female.
But we could do it by country,
or age, or anything like that.
Now we get into the
two types, and we
get into explaining that
value line that I explained
was something I'd explain later.
And we have two types
of events that happen.
One is a Boolean event.
It happens or it doesn't.
So I'm joining the news letter.
That is something that happens.
So there's not really
any interesting data
to record with that.
We just know that I
joined the newsletter.
But If I do something
like view a painting,
I want to record a bunch
of different information
about that painting viewing.
I want to know what
was the painting ID?
What painting did I see?
What artist made that painting?
What was the zoom level?
Maybe I should increase
the average zoom
on all my paintings.
I need to know all
this information
to make an informed decision.
But there's even more then this.
This is all great, and this is
stuff I want to have access to.
But I can also record
this value property.
And the value property
is something arbitrary.
In this case it could
be the amount of seconds
I spent on the picture.
I spent 84 seconds
staring at this picture.
And now, when I go
back into my dashboard,
it will chart that value
as the core integer metric
that I'm interested in.
So it gets a bunch
of interesting data.
And sometimes it'll show
up in different formats.
In this case, we're
tracking a level up.
So we just want to know--
we're reporting
a level up event,
and we're saying,
all right, we want
to know what level people are.
And it's showing up as
a histogram type thing,
where we can easily see that
the vast majority of our users
are level two to 20.
We have some who are
20 to 39, etc etc.
And that's coming from
that special value event.
And it doesn't have
to be in a histogram.
Not all data makes
sense in this chart.
So If we were reporting
virtual goods sales.
Imagine we had virtual
goods, like a single player
game, or a social game.
[INAUDIBLE]
Whatever these virtual goods
someone might be purchasing
are.
In addition to in-app purchase
data, which we get for free,
we can record this
specific data.
So we can see the value for
this virtual good purchase
event is this.
And we can make it show up
in a really wonderful table
like this, and can see
that the vast majority
of our virtual goods
are a single player
games that are being sold.
And then, of course, with that
we get all the enriched data
and cool charting that you would
get with any other Firebase
event.
So that's great, but
these are just actions,
Knowing what a person is
doing isn't a complete story.
We need to know who a person
is in order to truly enhance
the experience for them.
We need to know what they
like, and what their goals are.
And we need to know who
else is like them, so we
can predict what they'll need.
So imagine we have this guy,
and he has a whole bunch
of different facets.
As a person, like any person,
he has a fitness goal,
he has a way he
pronounces gif, he
has his favorite food, and
his favorite musical genre.
And all this information
is just custom information
that you can add to your app.
So if you need to know
favorite musical genre,
you can add what we
call a user property.
And once you add
that user property
it enriches the data you
have about your users,
and your ability to bucket them,
and filter them, and like I
said, enhance the experience.
So lets say we go and we
add in a user property
And we add favorite
food, for example.
And we just said your
favorite food is some type
of food, whatever they enter.
Now we'll have the
ability start filtering.
So favorite food
can be anything.
You'll notice in
these slides there are
a bunch of different examples.
Sometimes I'll
say, oh look, we're
setting a property
called favorite food,
and then the next slide
we're talking about
is there favorite color pink?
And the reason I do
this is to show you
how versatile this system is.
If you're selling food,
you can record about it,
and you can make
insight on that.
If you're selling
virtual goods, there's
insight to be had there.
If you're selling
carpeting, or whatever,
there's always something
interesting to know
about your user, so you
can start bucketing them
in more efficient ways.
So here's another example
related to painting.
If we went, and we added
a custom user property,
we'd go into the
console and we'd say,
all right, I'm going to
add a new user property.
The property in this
painting style, and we
add a little description.
And this is just so
Firebase Analytics
knows it should show
up in your dashboard,
and want's to see day that
this is being recorded,
and you want to be able
to view it So we go in
and create it in here.
And then once It's
created we can
create an audience using that.
So in this example we
want to make an audience.
We want to make a
group of our users who
are female Canadian shoppers
who are fans of [INAUDIBLE].
Now that's a pretty
specific group.
And if we say something
to that group.
If we had a push notification.
If we change the
background of the app
to be their favorite painter,
we change this or that,
we can really enrich
their experience.
And they might not even
know that we're doing it.
They might now know that
this app is shifting around
and changed just to
connect with them.
But they'll feel more
affected, and they'll engage
better because we did this.
So here we see we're
pulling together
a bunch of different
data that ranges
from that in-app purchase,
that built in event.
Have they ever made
an in-app purchase?
And we say [INAUDIBLE]
is bigger than zero,
so yes, they have at some
point made an in-app purchase.
Then we go and we use
that enriched Google.
And we say all right, if
their age range is 18 to 24,
24 to 35.
So that's the magic of Google.
Then we'll check the country.
Also magical Google.
So we'll say all right,
you are from Canada.
And then off, we'll use
that custom user property.
And we'll say you
specified you favorite
and said that was Raphael.
And now we have a
really complete idea
of who this person is.
Once we have a person, though,
that's-- this is where most
analytics products stop.
They give you an idea
of who someone is,
and then they just stop.
And they say, all right,
do something with it.
Like, take the
next step yourself.
And this is what really
makes Firebase amazing is
that we connect you into
other Firebase products
so that it's not
just information.
It's something you can act on.
So imagine we use
Firebase Remote Config.
And Remote Config is just a way
to set values in the clouds,
have your device receive
them, and then change
those values based on arbitrary
metrics that you set up.
So if I want to change
a message of the day.
This might be a
banner that shows up
on the top of the app,
something like that.
By default we'll use
this value down here.
"Remember, every day is the
first step to a better you."
That's a great slogan
for fitness folk.
But if you're in the runners
category, the runners audience,
and you specify it
there, we're going
to give you a message that
directly relates to running.
And this is a small
change, like I said.
But this could be anything.
This could be colors,
this could be pictures,
it could be huge
[INAUDIBLE] text.
It could even be
features in your app
that are only enabled
for certain audiences.
As soon as we set this up
it's now completely automated.
So if a new user comes in
and they're doing things,
and they eventually get
flagged as a runner,
or a female purchaser in Canada
between the correct ages,
they will see their experience
shifting around them
as your app starts
to know them better.
As they get bucketed
more successfully
you'll get a better and
richer experience for them
And since action is just
happening magically,
without you going in
and actually changing
anything or flipping any flags.
Once this is set up,
it's just an experience
that naturally hones itself,
and fine tines itself
for your users.
Another example of this
isn't just passive changes.
Like, those are great.
If we can tweak the app and
make it better for a user,
that's fantastic.
But what if we want to say
something to those users?
We want to really reach out
and say something specifically
to them to get some [INAUDIBLE].
If we think, for example,
Australian purchasers.
We have an audience of
just everyone in Australia
who every purchases
something form us.
We want to send them
a push notification.
We want to say, hey, we're
going to give you a [INAUDIBLE].
If you were using GCM,
Goggle Cloud Messaging,
or a different push service,
sending a push notification
to a specific
group would require
an entire other set of tools.
You'd need different
tooling just
to send a push notification
that hopefully integrated
with your analytics tool.
Maybe it didn't,
it'd be a huge pain.
With Firebase, it's
built right in.
So we can use the Firebase
notifications console.
Go in here, Say we're
going to compose a new push
notification, send it
to a user segment that
is that Australian
purchasers, and it will just
automatically handle all of
that looking up of ID tokens.
Everything you'd have to do
in GCM, or a traditional push
notification solution.
We just handle it for you.
And something very
subtle on this slide
that you might not even
notice is down here,
the conversion event.
So our goal here
is to get people
to make an in-app purchase.
So we're sending
out this $5 promo,
we're sending it to
Australian purchasers,
and our goal is to get
them to buy our thing.
And we'll tap this
[INAUDIBLE] that's
created that uses the built
in Firebase notifications
event in the core.
But It goes beyond
Firebase in the core,
because Firebase
is part of Google
It's part of this whole
gigantic, amazing company
of tools and products.
So if we stopped
at just Firebase,
we'd be missing half of
the opportunity here.
So Firebase will
actually integrate.
Firebase Analytics will
integrate with Adwords.
So there's a lot of
things you can do here.
But as just an
example, if I wanted
to target those
Australian purchasers,
and say my push
notification pretty well.
People really seemed
to engage with that.
But I want to see if I can get
more of those type of people
back.
I want to get them
back into my app.
You can import your
audiences into Adwords
and target those
people specifically
with remarketing campaigns.
So you can say hey,
we really appreciate
that you bought that in-app
purchase, why don't you
come back?
And so this reaches
outside of Firebase
into other services, like
Google Cloud and Adwords,
and all these other
Google properties.
Because we know that it's all
when it's connected together.
And this is just a
philosophy inside Firebase,
and if you use one feature it's
good, us a bunch it's great.
If you use the whole
suite and integrate it
with all parts of Google,
you're basically unstoppable.
Let's talk, speaking of the
extended Google ecosystem,
about Google Analytics.
How many people have ever
used Google Analytics?
[INAUDIBLE] of people?
[INAUDIBLE]
Most people have used
Google Analytics.
It's been around
for a long time.
Most websites, probably in the
world, use Google Analytics.
Don't quote me on that, I'm
not 100% sure that's true.
But it's very, very popular.
And it's easy to wonder how
do these compare and contrast?
Why would I use Firebase
versus Google Analytics
for [INAUDIBLE].
So some key points about
Firebase Analytics.
Why do we care about
Firebase Analytics?
One, it's free.
It's actually free, and
it is actually unlimited.
Almost every other
analytics offering
is going to cost
you a lot of money.
You'll pay by user, or
you'll pay by the number
of events logged, or whatever.
Firebase Analytics
isn't it like.
It is completely
free whether you
have 10 users, or 10 million,
or some other gigantic number.
And we prove that.
Many top partners use
Firebase Analytics,
and we charge none of them.
We also focus in Firebase
Analytics on events and users.
So some other
analytics offerings
will focus more on
page flow, if they
were coming from the web world.
Firebase Analytics is about
understanding users, enriching
your information
about those users,
and understanding
what they're doing.
So it's just a
different philosophy
about how to look at your users.
Then, Firebase
Analytics integrates
with the rest of Firebase.
Obviously.
This is what we've been
talking about this whole time.
The value of
Firebase Analytics is
that it goes beyond
Firebase Analytics
and goes into all these
other Firebase features.
This is something
no other analytics
tool can do because very
few of other suites of tools
have any offering even close
to the quality of Firebase,
with so many different
features that reach
into so many parts of your app.
And then lastly,
this is the only one
of these that may not be super
positive in your mind, which is
that Firebase is mobile only.
And the reason Firebase
Analytics is mobile
only is because we didn't
want to do a solution that was
OK for web and OK for mobile.
We knew that mobile was a
fundamentally different problem
then web.
So if we made an analytics
solution that worked OK
in both situations, we wouldn't
be doing anything innovative.
We wouldn't be
changing anything.
So we said we're not
going to focus on web.
We're going to build the
absolute best analytics
offering for mobile, and we're
going to do it only on mobiles.
Unless we can come up with a
way to do something equally
good on web, which
we feel like we've
already done with
Google Analytics.
So with Google Analytics
it is mobile and web.
You can use Google
Analytics on mobile,
but it's not a
natural situation.
Over the years
Google Analytics has
evolved from something
that records page views,
to something that
records events,
and the events are
mostly all page views.
So you can record
custom evens in mobile,
and there are some
SDKs to do it.
I But it's nowhere near
as natural and as powerful
as Firebase Analytics.
Google Analytics
is also just old.
It is very, very mature, and
it has really good support
for specialized reporting.
If you want to do
very specific things,
visualize very specific
flows through your app,
is something Google
Analytics can do.
And this is really,
really powerful.
You can do these types
of things in Firebase,
but right now it's
a bit more manual.
You have to export
it to another tools,
like data studio
that Google offers,
and build these
reports up there.
But Google Analytics
has it built in.
Google Analytics
also has a paid tier.
And I personally don't
know the exact dollar
value of the paid tier, but
this is very, very high.
You're doing good
until you hit that,
and then it gets
super, super expensive.
And is because at
that level you get
dedicated support and an SOA.
Now we have SOAs on Firebase,
but the dedicated support,
the ability to interact one on
one with someone inside Google,
is not something Firebase
Analytics offers today.
So, if you need that.
If you really wanted a
dedicated account manager,
Google Analytics
does offer that.
So if we're building
a mobile app today.
Just a mobile app, not a
cross platform experience.
Just an iOS and Android app, we
should use Firebase Analytics.
It is really just
generally better
for doing mobile app analytics.
If we're building just
a web experience today
we should still use
Google Analytics.
This thing's been
around forever.
There's a reason
people still use it.
It's an amazing product.
So if you're building just a
web app, use Google Analytics.
But what if we're building both?
What if we're
building an app that
is really important
we understand
our users between the platforms,
regardless of where they're at.
What do we do?
We use both,
And this immediately
just seems kind of weird.
Why would we use both?
They're different
products, I just
spent all this time
explaining that they're
very different products.
But we put a bunch of
effort into making sure
that Firebase Analytics feels
good with Google Analytics,
to the extent that
Firebase Analytics can
export all of its data
to Google Analytics.
So you have all these events,
all these interesting things,
all this insight on your user.
You can export that
into Google Analytics
and mix it in with
all of your web data.
So you can track
the same users right
form mobile into your existing
Google Analytics web stuff.
So there's a really huge
amount of opportunity
there for enriching the
data you already have,
and connecting your
mobile experience back
with your web one.
So to wrap up what
we talked about.
We talked about how to get
started with two lines of code.
We talked about how to
get all that benefit out
of all that built in data.
The Google magic of the built in
events, and the enriched data.
We talked about logging events,
which are one method call.
So another line of code there.
And we talked about
Google Analytics
and Firebase Analytics.
How to decide between them.
Take away there was
Google Analytics
for web, Firebase
Analytics for mobile.
And then we did this wrap up.
So some links for you.
Go to firebase.google.cn
for general documentation
about this.
More information.
And for Firebase Analytics
specifically, it will--
well, firebase.google.cn
will pretty much
get you there anyway because it
is very important for Firebase.
But if you're interested
only in analytics,
you can go to
[INAUDIBLE] /analytics.
And the last thing I
really want to push
is at Google we care a
ton about open source.
A lot of my job is
writing open source code.
A lot of my coworkers jobs
is writing open source code.
So if you're
interested in what it's
like to build software inside
of Google, what type of code
we write.
Spoiler, it's kind
of OK sometimes.
But we always make it a
lot better as we progress.
That's why we develop
in the open a lot,
because we love getting feedback
from people smarter then us.
So all of this, all of this
awesome stuff we're building--
Firebase alone has about 90 open
source projects of all sorts
of things, ranging
from scholar code
that we used as part of
the [INAUDIBLE] database
at some point, to
the integrations
with different
services, and tools,
and apps, and stuff
we built, for example.
So if you're interested in any
of that you can either go check
out my Github, or the Firebase
Github, at github.com/firebase.
With that, thanks for coming,
and if you have any questions
feel free to just grab me after,
and I'm happy to talk about it.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
INTERPRETER: So if I
already published app
and I start to use
Firebase, will Firebase just
come to new users,
or all the users
will be able to [INAUDIBLE]?
ABE HASKINS: If you don't have
Firebase Analytics installed
when you initially
publish you're app
you won't get any
data from those users.
So you'll have to
enable it form the
get go to start
collecting information
on every single user.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
INTERPRETER: I have a question
about the user properties.
How do identify that
a [INAUDIBLE] is
interested in Raphael painting?
How do you get that information?
ABE HASKINS: That's
the type of information
that's up to your app to get.
So you could prompt
the user and say,
what is your favorite painting?
Or you could get that through
looking at their activity
and saying, all right, this
person really likes paintings
from this person, I'm
going to mark them
as having this interest.
But we leave that pretty
open to the developer
to collect that type of
information about their
user.
AUDIENCE: So I have been using
Firebase for a long time.
In our product we can only see
the data over a period of time,
but you can not see
the data [INAUDIBLE]
divided by everyday.
So I just want to know
when the [INAUDIBLE].
ABE HASKINS: So you
were saying you only see
a subset of your data?
Or you can only see [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but I cannot see the data
[INAUDIBLE].
ABE HASKINS: Oh,
so you can't see it
on any daily level
of granularity.
That's a good question.
I'm assuming that's
something we're working on.
The amount of work
being done on Analytics
in terms of improving
the console and stuff
is just absolutely [INAUDIBLE].
So I don't know specifically
when that's coming,
but I know everything
related to the dashboard
and the console for
Firebase Analytics
is hugely high priority
for us to really get right.
So I'm guess it's in the
works, but [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: My suggestion,
you haven't [INAUDIBLE]
engineer [INAUDIBLE]
Firebase [INAUDIBLE].
ABE HASKINS: [INAUDIBLE].
All right, awesome,
Thanks everyone.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]